(Ethan:) Welcome everybody to the H3 podcast liiiiiiiiiiiiive
Today our episode is sponsored by quip and dollar shave club more about that later
I'm here with Hila Klein. (Hila:) What up pimps? (Ethan:) What up big pimps?
and incidentally this episode is also sponsored by a
(Hila:) Hila Kleiner (Ethan:) check out this shit
Check this shit out boy
Are you a Hila Kleiner for life? let the world know this is what like, the company would write about it
Are you a Hila Kleiner for life? let the world know by heading on out to represent.com/
H3h3 let them know that you're creative, funky, wild and free-spirited like Hila Klein oh
(Hila:) thank you (Ethan:) I was just talking like off off the uh
Off the podcast here before we went live how I feel like I'm becoming like a meme. I'm becoming a victim to Poe's law
(Hila:) Do you want to explain what poe's law is? (Ethan:) so poe's law is this like?
theory that when you're making fun of something and you get to the point where you're
Indistinguishable from what you're making fun of then you're then there's no difference
Then you're just that thing and I think that's happening to us because of, at first it was like, what up
Jake Paulers let's make fun of that by calling it Hila Kleiners
But now we're all saying Hila Kleiners not ironic at all and now we're actually selling merch that says what up
Hila Kleiners. Hila Kleiner for life.  (Hila:) It's still ironic, but not-
(Ethan:) it's getting, it's getting closer to not being ironic like I'm a legit, Hila Kleiner, and you can pick up the merch  today
at represent
.com/h3h3, but you see what I'm saying? (Hila:) I see what you're saying. I like the law
(Ethan:) you like the law? (Hila:) I like the, I like the name and therefore, I'm in
(Ethan:) and for all those reasons above I'm in um I
Feel like that happens a lot on the internet where you become victim of your own meme (Hila:) yeah, my first
Understanding of it was with keemstar
Because of his intro and we're like we were actually wondering like what happened, that made him
do this intro every time (Ethan:) it sounds like he's having a stroke every night on camera
(hila:) So I my the only explanation was it must have started as a joke
But then it actually became the thing right and now we affirm that with them now. We are like that. We
Like I used to say in the comments on YouTube
God bless and
I just thought that was such a funny way to sign off a comic. God bless
It's like what so then I started written writing that and all my comments on YouTube
It's responding people, and then I started seeing people being like "is Ethan religious?". Yeah, so that's the point
It's like the parody is not that obvious, so I'm just a religious guy saying God bless
Ya like I feel like I'm becoming the meme everyday more and more
But you know what you have to embrace the meme and that's the point
I think that's what poe's law was all about embrace the meme become the meme what up Hila Kleiner's
today we have a
jam-packed episode for you guys in
Honor of the net neutrality day of awareness that was I think yesterday
Anyone are they now I'm Wednesday. We put together a really great. I hope comprehensive episode about net neutrality
What is it? What's at stake?
Windows 10 I don't want to update
I'm about to go on a tangent on Windows 10 but I'm controlling myself. Stay focused yeah stay focused
What is it? What's at stake?
Who are the people who stand to gain from it and you know is there any arguments against net neutrality?
I Hope to answer all those questions as best as I can as interesting as possible
but first we have the news
speaking of which
We're trying to step up a little bit the format my dream for the show is to turn it into a whole Mishmash
Multimedia nightmare and by nightmare, I mean something pleasure
But for example today. We have a full segment of news stories
Awesome real some offbeat
and I want to try doing this every week if you guys enjoy it where we go over some some current events and
then we get into the either the interview or the segment the main segment and
Take it from there, so if that if that sounds good or not, you don't really have a choice this isn't that interactive guys
I'm gonna do it regardless
But highest I set my coffee
It's an experimental show right now. This is very experimental this coffee is really strong. I feel like I'm drinking acid
The main Oxygen I've been oh far
Is sake all right? Let's get started now recently on our most recent video
about the new humungous footage revealed I
Had encountered something I have never seen before on YouTube
And I think anyone who saw that video or visited the comments must have seen it as well. It was absolute fucking
Bananas let me pull the shit up
If you spend even one seconds time in there, you would have seen this I'm gonna need some help we can network
Here look at this yeah
this is
15 top comments are
All Spam bots all of them. I've never seen anything like this. How do I move this? What is this okay?
Here you go. Can you show it Dan?
Can you see it all right Dan?
Go, we have reached our goal of subscribers
Here's a special gift for you and a link
one two three and all the responses are spam Bots 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11
12 13 14 15 16
The 16 top fucking comments are all spam bots hurry up your goodies are waiting
Gift for my subscribers, so what I was wondering is like. How is this even effective at this point? I have no idea
It's so insane do you think that they would learn a little subtlety at this point?
This thing has been going on for at least a year
Maybe two years yeah, it's always been there
But I've never it's always like 1 or 2 but all of a sudden these spammers just turned into trolls and like
This isn't effective. I'm just going to ruin the Youtube comments
But my favorite part about it is when we made a video about it
Ethan was trying to become one of the spam bots
Right and you spend a bunch of links on everyone's Channel Jeff Dunham's website?
Yeah, not like weird short urls
It was literally Jeff Dunham calm and in response to that youtube actually
And they actually banned us, and we couldn't access our channel for a day you so fucking ban I
Love that this can happen for two years, but when you make a parody of it
We get there you get banned like sorry. We got to drop the ax on you ethan in Ela
These fucking guys this top comment right now two minutes ago. It has 1500 up votes
how is it possible for Youtube of all the big chat big companies in the world Owned by Google Ai
Machine-learning top comment two minutes second one three minutes these are all posted very recently and have over thousands of points
It's so unnatural, and they're all named a tradition productions. How is it possible that you're not catching this shit look at this?
The crazy part is that there must be like a couple people actually believe it well
I think that it sighs that's definitely true, but they've stepped up their game. They have fake verified badges
Yeah, because that was that was youtube's way of being like hey. This is the legit channel
so look at these fucking guys with their fake I
Think the real ones blue so they found a green but still it and also the real one will be next to your name
So they did it like right right right you know, but it's about it
But at first look for someone who doesn't know it looks real absolutely
Look at the stuff. They write is so dumb surprises for you fans. Take away their take it
I have a small surprise go to but here. So we're always like
Who just I haven't seen one person who buys into this stuff
But I did see one and I had to I had to save it
This guy says please stop posting all these fucking comments on your own video
The guy goes someone under he isn't it spots hey. I love that in this guy's mind somehow
I'm just spamming 15 times yeah, I
Would get banned if I did that
Anyway, if you guys stay tuned, I have a gift for all my subscribers
I don't have a small surprise for you guys check the link in the description for that condor you tick what is this?
Oh, yeah, this is a video. I took
have a
Journey into God. I don't know what's what desktop software, but it is so bad like I'm not very qualified pixel that yeah
Anyway, enjoy this Journey 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18
18 I count and that is kind of it, so hopefully what I did is I banned
Del use the same link here, and it's like dot T-- o-- or some shit
So I banned dot t-- o-- so I'm going to see if these guys are learning. I'm Gonna
I'm gonna play a little game with them. Whatever they're watching right now, and now they know let's go the game is on
YouTube can't Handle it. So now. It's time to dance and make these spammers on
Dot t-- o-- but something I've seen that they do is they'll say like hey. Have a gift for you
Type into Google x y z eleven twelve thirteen gibberish that only goes to their spam site
Yeah, so they have they have warfare these spam bothers are so advanced
It's crazy yeah that I'm afraid for the cyber security of the world
I'm telling you these guys are inside nuclear submarines right now. It's true. Like if they got this share. What else are they war town?
they're Brilliant and
And then sometimes they'll even impersonate the channel they'll throw them like oh yeah. Yeah, I used to happen cuz yeah
They're crazy man, so that's our top story watch out for the spam box guys. I mean clear
I don't think I need to tell anyone here that that's not me
That any time you see someone talking like a 4.1 person
Just to that one guy out there the next time you see what seems to be an Illiterate Chinese person
With a very spAmmy link. It's not me okay
Next up you want to take the lead on this one yella. What is it Ep? Dudes leader?
Viruses click the lead you okay this guy is a youtuber
everyone loves them on YouTube
leafyishere
exam so
He got his phone hacked or whatever Mike biggs. I'm sort of hacking happened. It was snapchat. Oh
Snapchat yeah and so
They got his nudes and it's all over Twitter now
So close your eyes when you're on twitter or not or not or open a lot, but watch out watch out, so leafy
his snapchat got hacked and
for some reason
I mean this seems a little bit silly to me to keep nudes on a snapchat when you know that you're like a high Target
400 unless he wants his dick out there. Which is you know God bless you?
Maybe he faked the hacking and you just wanted to show people as dick. I'm also a I was
I'd probably say this time you have a new son for his dick this channel down on the rope slightly everybody knows that
What better way to bring it back?
But like I was thinking I've never heard of a youtubers nudes being leaked
yeah, and not once and
You never hear almost even if guys
Nudes beam like it's always like females who are targeted?
Yeah, can we talk about that? Yeah? Let's talk about it. What's up with that all right? We talked about
I
Don't know I feel bad for him on one hand. I do I definitely do I
Wouldn't you know it's it's a horrible feeling? We you know we have been
Attempt though have been attempt to hack into our stuff, and it was really scary yeah
I'm not not a fun experience at all. No, it's horrible
So you feel so vulnerable yeah, and well, there's nothing more vulnerable than severe dick out on the internet
But again, it's like dude. I mean
I heat I feel like he has to take half the blame there he had a dick pic saved on his snapchat
That is pretty strange. It's kind of a strange thing
Mike, I don't use snapchat. Oh, so I'm not sure how
Weird is that they'll have will use. It's okay you you're like. What was on his phone?
What man was it honest what it means if somebody logs in your snapchat they get access to your dick yeah straight access
like me if I'm if I'm a celebrity
Here's my here's the good thing about being me nobody wants to see me naked
All right, my big pics are completely clear, but if anybody did want to see me naked and I was concerned about that I
Wouldn't keep any nudes man if you ever saw if you want to snap a picture of your dick send it
Here erase it
To the end other photo minute yeah, I mean yeah if you want to be dangerous
Then but then there's a chance that this would happen - yeah interesting
I haven't seen him comment about it, but just the fact that leafy of all the lectures day hey guys my dicks out there
But it's actually it's everywhere like anytime. I'm on Twitter. I'm seeing leafy's dick. I
Learned on that same day like I was just looking at completely unrelated to it and it popped up
It popped up literally
Well, we'd be next door and ears
I tell you something more to be said about that, but how much can you talk about leafies dick?
I'm going to talk about in a while, so it's kind of a good way to come in right? Oh
man
Yeah, that's embarrassing
If you like the older I get the smaller my dick gets alright, I get fatter my dick gets smaller so fucked up
You know what? I mean like yeah
You don't have to call me. I'm just talking like you know proverbial. I was hoping that this would be like a segment of news
Is this not a current event?
I'm trying. You know what I'm saying. It's like
You lose hair on your head your dick gets sucked into your fat your don. You've ever heard well, you know
Proverbial in the proverbial sense and you grow hair on your ass
I don't understand that you lose hair where you want it
You grow hair where you don't on your ears and your ass your ass crap fuck is that?
It's like it's already hard enough to get a date past 20. Why are you doing this to me life?
biologically
It doesn't even make sense. I'm evolved to fuck right. That's why you exist
Why you putting here on my ears in my ass and shrinking my dick?
That's all I'm saying can I get away oh?
Luckily I'm Gonna get an egg news story for you. Let's move it on
Next stories a little bit serious a little bit interesting
I've been I've been following this
The trump Russian story because I found it really fascinating
Try to be bipartisan as much as possible because I know we have a lot of fans who support trump a lot of people who?
Don't I personally just for transparency did not vote for trump, but I try to give everyone a fair shake on things
This trump Russia thing is kept as fascinating to me because it's if it all is proven true to me
It's just so crazy that like
one side of the political
system was colluding with with a
With pretty much an amine. I don't enemy who stays maybe a little harsh, but definitely an adversary you know a
competiting country competing country
And so you guys probably followed this story?
With a beef support trump just hear me out. Just listen. I'm gonna lay it out. It's fascinating
You should want to hear this more than anybody
Okay
let's start from here, so
The story had come out that trump Jr.. Had been talking to
- a russian some kind of Russian ambassador about getting information about Clinton
And and it just so happened that trump Jr.. And an attempt to defend himself or I guess be transparent
posted on Twitter a picture of his email correspondence with these russian dudes and
Any he pretty much admits to some really crazy shit
And he just tweeted it out. Which is fascinating let me read some of this stuff
So this guy he says hi, don. That's Donald Jr. But when you're free to talk with Mn. By phone about this hillary info
Mn. I presume is some kind of Russian diplomat you
Had mentioned earlier this week so wanted to try to reschedule a time and day best to you and your family
Thanks, Rob. I appreciate that. I'm on the phone at the moment, but perhaps. I just speak to Eman first seems
We have some time and it's what you say. I love it. Especially later in the summer
What could we do if we do a call first thing next week when I am back?
Good morning
Emma just called and asked me to contact you about something very interesting the crown
Prosecutor of Russia met with his father aris this morning and in their meeting offered to provide the trump campaign with some official documents
And information that would incriminate hillary and our dealings with Russia and would be very useful to your father
This is very obviously very high-level and sensitive information, but is part of russia, and it's government support for Mr.. Trump
What do you think is the best way to handle this information would you be able to speak with Emma about it just directly I?
Can also send this info to your father, but it's ultra sensitive. So wanted to keep send it to you first
So you told me that you should tell that point about Al gore so okay?
This this to me is is kind of mind-bending
I have a hard time even as like a staunch trump supporter that this wouldn't bend your mind a little bit
They you as a white this time. I trump a trump supporter
I don't know what I said sorry. I'm defensive ugh. You look like did you just say English?
That this wouldn't bend your mind a little bit
you have a
Russian Ambassador sending you incriminating evidence stolen from Hillary's email account
Trying to influence the campaign on your behalf
I'm not sure. What are the counter points to defending that because I know as supporters do defend it. They say well
Who's troubled not to accept help if somebody wants to help them even if it happens to be an adversary?
Someone who it's best interests aren't the United States
so people would say well hillary's a a
Criminal and she deserves to be outed or whatever it's like an issue of morals right? It's a conflict of interest is what it is
Yeah now to put it lightly lightly but but the biggest problem here is that trump and his campaign?
And his son and everyone involved has come as always
said with a
Absolute definitive way we haven't had contact with the russians about any of this stuff
Yeah, that is crazy. So on one hand all these counter points of defense is like okay
We could talk about that, but the thing that I'm worried about is why have they denied this relationship for so long?
And pretty aware it if it was going to come out eventually why?
Why lie about it all the time?
I don't know that they thought it was going to come out eventually but but you can see here even in this in this
Short Correspondence, he says they sent it to your father
And he says in the best interests of your family which would imply that
they all knew about this from all of them right, so
that the lines and the kind of that what seems to be an attempt to covering up this story a
Lot of people saying why did he tweet this out because it's like obviously incriminating people laughing saying he's just dumb
He's dumb he would dump their idiots. I don't I don't think that's the case
Probably most likely is that because the New York times was digging into this and they probably
Figured that it was going to come out
And I think this was his if I had to guess I would say he's trying to get ahead of the story
Because it was going to come out anyone you got you want to you want to control the information as much as possible you don't
Want to give the control the New York times?
to me, this is pretty much I
Don't know it whether it would I don't know the whole thing is just so
Crazy it's it's spooky. Yeah. I don't trust the russians to be meddling in our and our governance and
You should tell about that point that you told me about al gore. Oh yeah, and so okay again
Look, I'm not trying to trigger. Anyone. I'm jen. I know this is very contentious to talk about this stuff
But this is pretty this is like the most smoking gun on this issue. This is pretty serious stuff here
Now people are saying
You know here let me let me compare this to something okay back
Let me find this
How do I not have been info yeah, but it's funny how it's all about the emails
I know this got a fucking ironic. Isn't it after all this shit. There's this email. That's coming back to haunt trump, Jr.. Oh
Man, you can't write it better than this house of cards has nothing on this shit
it's like he had youtube with Twitter DMS and
Fucking opposed to their damn they raised forever
so
Just for comparison
Now al gore when he was running against bush
It was back in 2008 if I recall correctly
Had received information about Bush's debate questions
So he found out what?
Questions bush was going to be asked during the debate that gave him a hugely unfair advantage because you could compare he could prepare
counter points
They could prepare zingers it gave him an absolutely unfair advantage and the first thing al gore did
When receiving those documents is he handed it over to the FBI?
because
It's the right thing to do he says
Someone's trying to Meddle in our democracy. There's an external force at play here
Who's trying to control the outcome of our democratic process?
This belongs in the hands of the FBI the Cia
Because I think when you have external forces trying to manipulate the outcome of American democracy
They need to be challenged
You know and and the thing that's most disturbing to me about what's happening with trump and supporters is their seemingly?
willingness to
Be okay with the fact that russia aided
Campaign and he he accepted the help and he does and they don't see any problem with that Mm-hmm
The sway of Public opinion, and everything I don't know about like voter fraud
I don't I don't I don't personally believe or haven't seen evidence that Russia like was hacking voting booths or anything like that
There was there's as far as I could tell was clearly a war on the hearts and minds of of the voters
But doesn't it I?
Don't know it's it's strange
The fact that russia had a preference on candidate because Clinton was notoriously very hard on Russia and putin in general
she was a hard-ass and
Trump seems pretty fucking soft he talks shit on everybody
Everybody he's talk shit on every world leader
Even people in his own party know Marco Rubio Low-energy. He shits on everybody somehow
Putin is this glorious horse riding fuck who has never done anything wrong who has never assassinated?
Political opponents who didn't just make a war mongering land-grab in ukraine
He's the fucking great like I'm just saying it's it's concerning I
Think that everyone. I think that people should be concerned about this
That's my part. I don't know
People saying next what do you guys know?
well, this is not a political show so I don't want to get too much into detail about things like that because I did just
Give you anyway, whatever that's my thought. I thought I find the whole thing fucking interesting
Let's move it on let's get light now
Next story is a great one that you guys are going to love
Anheuser-busch
Ex-Ceo
Augustus isle Duffus busch the fourth
subscribe natural named
Augustus Al dolphus bush the fourth was arrested for flying his helicopter while drunk
His story is a crack-up. Do them everything in this story. You gotta like read twice to make sure you heard it, right?
It's such a great headline the former ceo of ana Hazzard bush. His name alone is Unbeliev, Augustus, El Dothis bush
The fourth was arrested after he landed his helicopter and Illinois' business parking lot Monday
He landed his healthop there in a parking lot. I'm going to show you the video
Swansea Police said in a Facebook post officers were dispatched to report a helicopter landing for unknown reasons around
1 o'clock in the afternoon, and we're concerned about the aircraft taking off again due to closed obstacles and buildings
After 7 hours police said they received a call saying the pilot identified as bush appeared to intoxicated to take off
The helicopters rotors were spinning and the engine was revving up when officer arrived on the scene
That is terrifying listen to this shit
Bush's wife
Dewanna wood was with him at the time in addition to their eight dogs
There was eight dogs in the helicopter. That's a fucking party dude
But how do you forget about drunk driving?
Let's drunk fly drunk not even for helicopters. You're more complicated flying an airplane
Let's drunk ass by a helicopter into eight
Public partners in a neighborhood you got to see the video ever it is so funny after a second officer arrived on the scene
the police
administered eyes field sobriety tests
Bush appeared unable to keep a single train of thought and his speech appeared mumbling and slurred, but he blew a zero
Because because he was fucked up on pain gas Korea tells ishe say it wasn't drunk. But you exact. Which is probably even worse
He's like knocking imagine nodding off in a helicopter like nodding off in a car
You crash, and you're probably fine you get out yeah, you're not often a health on there. It's your last news
It's different levels of adventure. Is that you can crash into a house and
I don't even know don't be like hell. Yeah. They're like little family people
so I hate flying like
By percentage flying is much safer than driving, but when you crash an airplane
Your your brad buried can we get a soundboard sound for that dent when you crash an airplane. You're I?
Would sound oh you are just waiting to see what he chooses I
Didn't hear it. Oh, we didn't hear it
Did people oh?
Thank you, Dan these into use real fast
That's a great story. Let's see here a
further search of the helicopter turned up several loaded weapons
weapons still and Several bottles of prescription drugs
so this motherfucking gun is a helicopter with eight dogs and much lighter weapons his wife and and
tons of pain pills
Watch this for you I?
Can't let's point out no charges have been filed in this case
But here's a look at where this chopper landed and give you a sense of what's around here
This is just a parking lot in the middle of an office park
You've got a dumpster a few feet away from where that helicopter landed and you can see just some of the other businesses
I wonder what he was doing there
I wonder if he's just picking up a Papa John's of some shit like what the fuck
Did you need to land your helicopter there no?
I think he landed there because he felt unsafe, but he was about to get back and take off
Yeah, okay, so that was an emergency landing yeah
Oh, maybe I'm too fucked up
But I I don't know I'm not sure maybe I hate called the cops right or not a driver
Ya know one of the store merchants called the police
Oh my and they're like yo this drunk idiots about to take off in his helicopter and feels mankind
I think he dropped he stopped off for Papa John's I
Need to talk to his wife
She didn't shoot a bear
She's chilling with the dogs and back there having a great time. It's probably their favorite, Hobby
My passions include getting fucked up on Oxycontin and fly my helicopter
He wants a lift just say quality time with our dogs
Dogs are all freaking out of business
Here again, this is ian. Swansea a big office Park here witnesses tell us
They wondered what the world was happening when the helicopter landed in the middle of this office park
now
Swansea police say the pilot told them he was visiting a business here now according to
My sources august push the forwarding to my sources for the passage on or large
Some crazy sticks could you say them?
It's just laughing at is there I mean here and say no no no, Fontana
Sources august bush the fourth was the pilot in that chopper when it landed now police
investigate it because they had concerns about
How safe it was to land in the area that rich people will be doing whatever the fuck they want
I'm gonna park in this parking lot by the way. No charges were filed what that's what? He said, no charges have been filed
Really all you gotta be is rich and you can park your helicopter in some broke people's house for all they care
Wow, just we have the commissioner a couple hundred thousand
That's a lot of my God bush. That's with the bush family
That's for me this guy's old money. He's bush the fourth several hours later witnesses anyone called algar that
Justice you know next person you mean named Augustus. You know his ass got money
he's got helicopter money thanked it appeared the pilot was intoxicated and trying to get back into the helicopter and
fly it out of here sources say bush the fourth was mumbling and had trouble walking a court order was sought for a blood and
Urine sample he was taken to a hospital where those samples were taken now
The swampy Police Chief says because no charges are filed as of right now
He's not confirming the pilot was in fact august bush the fourth
We're not confirming it was august bush the fourth, but I've been one of the dogs
We don't know if it was one of the dog driving
We can't confirm his identity no charges have been brought
He he was he appeared in the parking lot fucked up with a gun on him and pills on him. We can't confirm it
He was him flying though, and so we're gonna let him off the hook
get real
All right next story. That's a pretty spicy one though, I
Love his name so much August's alphys bush the fourth
It's actually just august it's got to be a gusta s' yeah, I'm gonna rewrite this one
August is not
Not fascinating for me man tries to murder a friend over argument of Star Wars for Star. Trek. I
Love this. This is the kind of articles that live for
police
Fight over star wars and star trek led to assault look at this fucking guy
Do you think this guy was onto the side of Star Wars or star trek?
Jerome white 23 was arrested july 1st in Oklahoma city on a complaint of assault and battery
serious business y'all
Police say a fight over star trek and star wars led to an assault
Jerome
Wyatt 23 was arrested july 1st on a complaint of assault and battery
Oklahoma City Police Department reports show that weiss had it thought like what if they were arguing about something
Else and then the police came, and then they're like trolling the police and it's like oh, we were just arguing about
Star Trek
rule
They're gonna cover it up. How do you confirm what they were arguing about well, okay?
So my that's a really good point my thought is these are probably not the brightest people I?
Don't know how oh
Yeah, well if you were arguing about drugs or something illegal. You would say we had an argument
yeah, but if let's say if you were trying to like
Stick it to someone or whatever the phrase is by saying like something really dumb
That's what that's the kind of thing you would say that's a fucking Brilliant point
Kind of just ruined this whole story
Well anyway, the story is wyatt literally followed a man. He says here. This is this is the from the police report
Oklahoma City Police Department reports that white and another man were in the living room apartment
They shared when they began arguing if star wars as star trek was better
The Victim Told police he became frustrated and stated
You're just a trick before walking
To his room
White allegedly followed the man and shoved into the ground the victim got back up and told police he stated you want to replay that
And once again shoved to the ground police say wyatt then wrapped his arm around
The Victim's neck and began choking him the Victim was near unconscious when he pulled out a pocketknife
Wyatt let go and reached for the knife cutting himself then left the room
So dan pointed out and I think it's a good it's a really good point
They don't know they don't say who supported star wars and who supported star trek
Yeah, that's kind of fucking important to resolving this and my hunch on this is that
The guy who choked him had to be the star wars fan because Jean-Luc picard would neither advocate in this kind of behavior
It's true. You have to live by the code of Star trek
So anyway, I think you killed that story from so if I'm being honest, I think these guys are probably
The greatest troll I think they're trying to please
But if you're getting stabbed and choking each other out are you in the state of mind to be like can't control the please?
What I just I don't know. I think you're on this make sense in my mind. Yeah the police come and they're like
What was this argument about and then the doors were star trek? Yeah?
Yoda you know yoda young
All right
This is a short one, but gave me a giggle for sure white house misspells inaccurately in video accusing the Cbo of inaccuracy
Look at this shit
The fuck is this guy okay? Here's the screenshot. So they made this really dramatic kind of like
Where's that videos? I have the source video just the screenshot. I guess I don't they made this really dramatic
I didn't I don't know what this is about. I didn't know what the cbo is it's not about that
It was really dramatic kind of Propaganda video about the cbo, and then I said in
accurately estimated 25 million would be covered under obamacare, but they misspelled and accurately a
Little bit of A meme a little bit of a story
it's a bit of a scoop was a bit of a spoof a bit of a spaz as
It were moving on
That one didn't hit too hard a story didn't hit too hard
This is our first time wearing how this goes
So you guys may have seen this picture which is
become a meme on the internet of itself this picture of Marco Rubio in
Nasa
Let me see here
Hello is anybody home this would
Well it will fucking internet. You know at times you're out
What is this shit and?
This brings me to the point of this video about net neutrality throttling our interviewed
So here you can see
you guys probably seen this picture of
Mike Pence the vice president
Touching a thing on that and Nasa that says please do not touch and he stared cuz with his hand on it
and
So he tweeted out a week after everyone was meeting on him. He said sorry, Nasa Marco Rubio dared me to do it
This is his actual
This is his actual Twitter account vice president Pets. Sorry, Nasa Marco Rubio dared me to do it
Somebody's I
This for campaign this is this insane to you guys that mark pants and mark Mike pence and Marco Rubio walk around, Nasa
Touching shit like a candy store some shit
It's a picture is amazing
The fact that it says right there not the types here it is. This is like a historic picture
I like this and a hundred years from now. This will be in history books
critical space flight hardware do not touch and sold red letters
And here's Mike pence without cracking a smile his hand for no reason no purpose on this beautiful and critical
spaceflight hardware
Mike sorry Mark Mark. It's Marcos fault he told he dared me to
I'm not sure like how old is Mike pence. He's like 60
I'm not sure even at the age of fifteen. I would be done here
Look at his face. He's so sincere. Oh
Man, so that's fucking good right, okay living at home. Oh
This is when itoh found this morning. This is from Israel. Oh
Look at this video. Yeah, so you guys should enjoy this woman destroys
$200,000 worth of art in pursuit of taking a selfie oh
My God excuse me. Oh
Jesus
How do I need to read the article because the video speaks for itself watch this shit? It's so brilliant this footage is incredible
Watch the top right yeah
The top right you can see this lady. She's about to kneel down in front of it
And they're the dominoes oh
Okay, so those were sculptures. I guess rare ancient
Expensive sculptures, and they toppled over like a fucking row of dominoes
Yeah, time of your thousand dollars. Yeah, and three of them were like permanently damaged or something
You stupid idiot. Why would you leave first of all?
But also the gallery yeah, there's a pretty shitty job here
I take half the curator and half her fault he'll glass no Rope I
mean in this day and age you got to expect that somebody's going to want to Domino your
selfie Domino to your ship
okay, how are we doing so
Dan did you end up making that Shark tank season four intro?
Fuck yeah, okay moving on
Moving on to our next topic. I've been been watching binge watching Shark tank. I'm obsessed with
That show we're both obsessed. I can't stop watching
I don't know how many you guys watch Shark tank
But it's like you expect it to be really bad because it's just it's a reality show and you know
All reality shows are pretty shitty. It's like Force drama
But this shows real as a heart attack
If you guys don't know the premise they have like all the super wealthy billionaire cap investors
And they have people with real ideas come on the show
And they spend their real money investing in these people and it's fascinating
It's riveting and dan can you play the soundbite and for those reasons? I'm out. Oh
And for those reasons and for those reasons you're out
Also, what happened to the accurate?
My sound is a creative play that you have the accurate my sours accurate. It's like 15 minutes late
We're going to play that when they misspelled accurate
But now you guys know we have it
Do you have anything like yeah blew it hmm?
Can you okay?
Anyway, Shark tanks and fucking been fascinating me and
They always do this thing well
We're supposed to have the soundboard though. Is that thing where they go?
when they turn people down
Which is like 90% of the time people come in and they have like no business plan they have no reason being there
They've just been a business that off any income and they go for those reasons
I'm out and now I've been saying that about everything in my life
I'm like dealer does that sandwich come with lettuce no and for that reason. I'm out
And we're supposed to have the sound bite
But here's what I was thinking because I'm so obsessed with Shark tank. Can you put on that clip by the way damn?
I'm gonna see it on twitch. How do I watch it? Oh?
It's on the TV
I'll just watch I have to watch it on my own stream. How can I react to it?
Well because if you want to see it on the TV. He has to switch to the hMI cable yet
Oh, I'm watching my own stream to react
Alright look at these fuckers look at these Goofballs, man
Damien they get the black guy in the middle
He walked so funny his hands they'll move I just am fascinated by the day. I'll kind of walk funny if you're focused on
They're so great like watch mark on the left
He's got like a waddle
Walks like a turkey or some shit, but damien move your hands swing your arms dog. Oh here. Yeah, Kevin o'leary, Mr.
Wonderful this guy calls himself Mr.. Wonderful, but he's such a character
I love him he always he comes out with the most beautiful analogies to disc people thinking. I'll never forget he goes
This one about like the leopard seals who jump in first indeed
This person came in without a business planning he goes
He goes every summer in Alaska
There's a group of leopard seals that jump in the shark-infested waters. There's always one
Who's the hungries who has to jump in first and most likely he's going to get eaten?
But he saves all the other seals should all the other seals in this story
That's you you came into us unprepared and we ate you a lot let this be a lesson to all the other
Sea lions gone like damned this guy's like Shakespeare
And then also when he's like not into someone he says and you're dead to me, and you're dead to me
Oh, you got to get that dan we need that
okay, you're dead to me he goes and
Someone doesn't take one of his deals
You're dead to me get out feel like we all need to like watch an episode together
Just straight-up watch it anyway, so this is what I was thinking
I
Love the show so much
Tell me why think about this what someone says you ran for office in Canada Kevin o'leary. Yeah, oh my God
I'm not sure I would vote for him because he's like. How is he gonna be as a public service
This is very well be terrible all about the money all I care about is money
I'm not sure. I want that guy in public service. Yeah
They're like someone will come be like I invented a new drug that cures aids
It cures aids, but what about the money?
We don't operate at our profit. All right. We're all purely humanitarian. What about the money. I'm out to me
You're dead to me. I know no thing. I want to vote. I love the guy not bogos anyway
Trying to step the show up add some more texture some more layers more segments. So here's what I'm thinking I
Want to make my own version of the shark tank. I'm going to call it the Fishbowl
We're all you guys out there with business plans or existing businesses, or ideas can pitch your shit to us
We'll set up an email. You send us the details about your business your business plan your revenue all this shit
And we'll evaluate it
and we're going to pick like the top ten to come on the show, and it's repeating segments called the Goldfish Bowl yep, and
the Winner gets
fifty thousand Dollar Investment from Us
For I don't know what equity we'll decide on the equity
Well it depends on the page
That's yet all the hedge about the deal the thing is I can't really afford more money than that. I don't have companies
I'm not a billionaire. I can I can afford fifty thousand investment
I think I'm hoping I'm planning on making my money back from this genius
Whoever it is
So I'm just maxing out fifty because I assume if I'm like I have fifty that everyone's going to ask for fifty so the prize
Is Fifty Mm-Hmm?
Here's the great thing guys you get all the power all of the support of the H3 nation
We're going to go slanting for you, because we're going to be business partners. I'm talking social Media. I'm talking YouTube channels
Whatever you got we're in let's make a lot of money together and for that reason. I'm in
What do you guys think what do you think that'd be a fucking great segment, right?
I think it could be like over a whole season of this podcast or something yeah
It would have to be like ten a few months like a reality show of like
We get the pitches we go over them. We narrow it down to like ten and then we've kind of narrowed
Down to the top one that won't end up in assyrians people watching live can also help folks yeah, we can even have votes right
So we're not set up yet, but I want to throw the idea to you guys sounds fun start thinking about your pitches start
Yeah, I mean, I'm looking for people with existing businesses. I'm not looking for some guy
Who's like my idea is to make an app that will show you where the closest bathroom is
That's I'm sorry phil. It sounded a really good idea to be honest
So I think next episode will start. I'm going to set up an email, and I start getting your guys's
Applications and then the next episode after that we can start the segment called Fishbowl
Fishbowl
$50,000 online that's a lot of money. Let's make a lot of money together
That's exciting okay moving on
So here's another new segment. We're working on called. What's trending on YouTube and
I mean
I don't know if you guys ever when you're on youTube pop on over to the trending tab but I've seen some of the most
godless
Unholy I don't want going through religious theme. You've arrived
Obscene garbage ever and it's always this interesting thing of like why of all the things to YouTube trend is because when YouTube trends
A video it's very intentional it's neither. It's never accidental even though they want admit it
It's got a very tensional it's a it's not even debatable. It's 100% a channel and so I
want to go every week and go on the Youtube trending tab and see what's there and
I've got one let's go there and see what's on trending today. I have one video from over the week
I want to watch to go because it's just it was so fucking ridiculous
My God, let's see let's see
This week on what's trending on YouTube?
And you have the link I do but let's see if there's anything interesting training today
Selfie Domino, we just talked about that
It's all about the boxing
But tell me there's not something weird. It's all talk shows it's all promotional shit the daily show it's all about this fight
Music videos I refuse to believe that this music video
French Montana's famous, but the studio the computer then
Is you know I think it's showing you french, Montana ally has 300,000 views in seven hours
There's thousands of channels to do that. Let's trend that why okay?
Jimmy Kimmel 18 hours 300,000 views you're telling me that there's not a little foul. Play there I
Don't know kid Rock new music video 150,000 views in 19 hours. That's never been done before
But usually there's some really words the vlogbrothers
70,000 views and the thing is like there's always the same channels like Natalie as a people every time despite
anything amount of views
Time Mathias has been on there every fucking day the vlogbrothers are there every day
There's no way that he's legitimately training with 70,000 Casey and I said
It's pretty much every week pretty much every single video Kasyapa. Lows goes to trending Liza
Is there every time all of a sudden there's only five channels on YouTube?
But where is that warning video? We want to talk about yeah, very rarely where there's actually like a legitimate like
worthy video here like here's one Jenna marbles
She's on. She has 2.2 million views I believe that I believe that our ending and that's probably something someone would want to watch
But here let me show you one video that caught my eye
Over the past week that was on training and this is probably
one of the most obscene examples of
Fuckin second one sec. I got open this document. Are you feeling you tell me about yourself wait. Are you going to be?
Tell me about yourself eula
um I
Think I had the news segment is pretty cool. You like it
Yeah, how do you guys like the new segment so far as again? I'm just opening this document, but after this we'll
Take a break and then get into the net neutrality stuff just in case people are wondering I can open this fucking folder
Hold on one sec fuckin shared with me
Okay, here. It is alright
So this one is called
this video was called
Parents explained masturbating to their kids. I think that was the exact oh parents explained masturbation. This was on
the top Trend
I think it topped out at number three on the trending you can see here was number six at a time of the screenshot
It's called parents explained masturbation. Yeah, and it doesn't have that many views
300,000 Views I
Checked YouTube says trending is based on full blog posts
Yeah, like how much it's been shared on other websites horseshit, I
Source the links on this video. It's not posted anywhere. It's the same for any any video on that trending page
They're not being shared anywhere on the internet now. It's ridiculous to claim that
So this video was on number two trending at its highest point didn't have that many of you has nothing remarkable by any means
But even Beyond it
The video itself is pretty one of the top Columns was H2 issue should react to this
Even Beyond the fact that this video is really kind of disturbing and and not not that great is
The fact that Youtube made the conscious decision to trend this and keep it up despite
Everyone on YouTube losing their fuckin mind like let me look at the comments here
They also say that trending is for the purpose of discovery they think that videos on trending are a good show. Oh
I got age-restricted well, it's a little fucking late for that. God, okay
They finally age-restricted it was up there for like five days. It was everyone who reported it
So they finally I just care like
That's pretty fine though because those kids in the video
That's that is that's youtube doesn't make any sense you a little bit of a conflict there
This is shit this video featuring five year old is not you have to be at least eighteen to watch it
Even though it's about educating
five-Year-Olds
Wow, that is pretty I can see that the moral conflict they had I think that they didn't necessarily need to age-restricted
But the fact that they consciously put this on trending and kept that there is what disturbed me
um
Let's watch it. I
Can't I can't hear it then oh?
There you go, or I guess I should preface this by saying that I don't I think that sex education is important
And I think that in the united states is way too much shame and embarrassment surrounding sex
Yeah, I agree with that, but those kids are pretty young. I don't know like they
just shine them like sex toys, and I
Mean you should watch it. I don't know it's a weird
It's a weird visual thing that disturbed me is the fact that they like filmed it for entertainment
Because this is an educational. This is entertainment Mm-Hmm, right?
This is not what educational looks like this is content for like adults to be entertained by like oh kids
It's just really I don't know it's really embarrassing it just feels wrong and I chose
Voyeuristic to me in a really gross way snake
today
We are going to be talking about
masturbation
Masturbation like this is a private conversation you have with your kids
Yeah, you don't you should have filmed this and show it to millions of people humiliate
Very strange, and you know the producers are like mobile mobile more Vulgar Mm-Hmm more detailed
Talk about tricking up. Yeah
Fuck it. Oh
Gracious masturbation, you kind of do it a lot really but you know it
Masturbating is when you touch your private in
Different ways watch us get age-restricted know you by talking about it
Make yourself feel good
Is that right? Yeah? That's a good point. We probably should not watch should we just not that's how fucked up is Kel
We really can get a district if we're talking about this yeah
We would I
Want to watch it. This is such a shame, but I think you're right
And smell so it's what I was getting aids inflicted on the whole episode is all conflicted about this right now
Yeah, right. I think you're right. It's such a shame
All right, fuck it. Let's move on I'm so retarded
YouTube
Everyone is like. It's too late not too late too late. We did show thing. We didn't even show anything yet, baby
Jess and II like dildos to 5y feels like big-ass black cocks. Yeah turns into like an episode of black
What is that? I took a four that were likes women wouldn't little white girls, but like black dudes I?
Anyway, I'm on the internet. You know anyways anyways good observe black this video was great
Definitely check it out on your own check it out
Where were we so that's pretty much wraps it up for our segments and news clips
hope you guys enjoyed that let me know what you think because if I
My plan is to continue this at the beginning of every episode say we had a guess they would walk in at this point
Mm-Hmm, and then we'd do that guest segment
But this week our main segment is about net neutrality, and we will get started on that but first before that
We have a flippin heck in
Ad
Scott I was reading the chat again
I'm looking at the chester last hello, hi Jen
I cannot look at the child so it's like so this should you can't you just can't look at it?
I won't screaming like cut it. I hate it, but I don't know if they're talking about the video. Oh
They were saying that before and but the video
Cut the whole thing so that we don't get a trick to cut that part. Hope you guys enjoyed that segment I
Also, want to talk about something almost forgot this game. I'm obsessed with this game
Player unknown you're reading the chat you'll you guys well here. I talking to you, and she's like a wall
She's not even acknowledging that here. We're doing that live show you didn't even fucking listen
He's the only person in this room alright loves it letting everyone know
I'm not what kind of a chat your guys's fault all right? We'll look at it and during the breaks and after yeah good
I'm obsessed with this game player unknown battleground yep, last night
This game no, it's it's captivating. It's one of the most interesting of fun games. I've played in a long long time
I've been playing overwatch a lot and it's got so boring for me, and this was exactly what I was looking for
It's like you come in on an airplane with a hundred people you parachute into this big open space world
And it's a battle royale to see who's the last one standing and you loot all these houses. It's super intense
It's really hard actually because you got to be like it's real
Oh, I need this gun with this piece that goes with that gun
And then you need those bullets takes a little bit of a rain man. I'm not playing by the way
I'm just watching him. He love watches. She's my military advisor my last night
We made it to numbers to number two of a hundred and like I suck
So this was a huge thing for me like I played
beautifully
and it came down that I was in a little hut and the
Thing is the really really cool thing about this game
Is that every let two minutes or so the space and the map?
Decreases and there's this huge blue dome that squeezes in on you
And if you're caught outside the dome as it squeezes in you lose health
I didn't realize at the end that you lose help faster Mm-hmm
So it's down
I'm in a little hut and
The Blue dome is close to almost like a pea size on the on the sides of the map just me and this other fucking
Guy and I shotgun at bitch, so I was blasting people in the face of my shotty bite
Was insane Eva was like fully turned on
And so I'm in this room and a little high and the other dudes outside
And the mini-map is getting under the spheres getting so small that I'm right on the cusp. I thought I was inside and
I didn't realize it's gonna die so fast, but the blue orb closes in and I just fucking died in this room
Yeah, that's like. This is not how this game is supposed to end. It's high Octane its high intensity
I just dropped dead in a room and the other guy won. I got second place is so disappointing
I think I would want if I want to want to out there guns blazing, but it was cool
do I
Recommend that game a lot if you guys ever want to catch us playing head on over to twitch where you are now
Where you are now, but on youtube you're not there push that TV slash a straighter production
We can watch the podcast live every Friday, and you can catch us playing that game and doing other stuff
Okay, so before we go on a break. I want to thank our sponsors
They're the ones who make this possible. I love our sponsors man
This whole thing this whole studio this whole office dan out there with the switchboard can I get a sound dan?
Let me sunbright batteries. I want to be possible without the gracious support of our sponsors
So I'd like to say thank you to first of all quit
Quit is actually amazing product. Yeah, they make an electric. Toothbrush that's super affordable and it works amazing
It's it's a we've been actually using it since they sent us that one
I'll be using it every day for the past month and like
It's it's great. It was named Time Magazine's best invention of 2016
It's really cool. It's an electric. Toothbrush you put it in your mouth as you do toothbrushes
And it like basically tells you every 30 seconds. It will stop vibrating for a moment. That's my favorite feature about it
It stops after three minutes right if you're about to like pause before that you know there's still keep trailing dude
Yeah, you disgusting monster keep brushing not you, but it's what it's telling
It's an amazing thing and it's super. It's like 25 bucks something
I actually don't know the exact price, but it's very affordable
It says here yet starts at 25 dollars okay, and it lasts and really lasts. I'm going to read their copy
Here's something that you want. I love reading copy because I think
You're something that you on many recent studies suggest that having good oral health impacts your overall health
Yet most of us don't brush our teeth properly. I feel like there's a better argument you
Have a disgusting breath your breath is discussing no one wants to stand next to and smell you
You're never going to get data. No one wants to kiss you
Yeah, okay. It makes you healthy people don't want to fucking look at your disgusting mouth. That's why you need quit
Introducing quit the new company that's refreshing the way people brush their teeth clip is an electric
Toothbrush the packs premium vibration and timer features into a ultra slim design that's half the cost of bulkier brushes
This is my favorite line. It's basically like apple designed a toothbrush, but without the big price tag
You have to see it and brush with your so. I don't know about that apple. I'm Gonna give
They're saying it's sleek its modern. It looks cool. I prefer if they said it looks like well
I am design that would strike home with me a little bit more well
I had a new invention, but then it would not be functional. It would have weirdo just blow up in your mouth
You can subscribe to receive new brush heads on a dentist recommended three month plan for just five dollars including free shipping
Right now my friends you can head on over to quick calm slash
H3 to get your first refill pack free with a quip electric toothbrush that's a faux read
By the refill time their link is not working
Did we crash the website again? Oh no?
No, quick calm slash H3 did we seriously crash their website? I think we crashed some last time too
That is strange because we didn't get quit. Did you write in the right? You are an equipped comm h 3i?
I personally on a personal level I
Recommend this product I've been using it. It's so hard to find like soft Bristles
I hate these hard bristles that you get at the grocery store
And I've always been on a search find a soft one and they have like a really wonderful
rubber kind of really soft texture and
I I love I've seriously been using everyday so support the show if you're in the market for New Brush get quit by shot
I think you'll like a lot when their websites back up
When it probably would be back up soon as well
Try to do a spot for you guys, huh all right next up quit. Thank you cliff for sponsoring our show next up
We have dollar Shave Club
You guys know dollar shave club. They're one of our
oldest and best Sponsors
They've been
Supporting us through thick and thin and I just have so much love and appreciation for these guys in the great product they make
Dollar Shave Club is the smarter choice
Get a great shave at a great price to beat and lead delivered right to your door. It's an awesome life hack
They wrote life hack
It's not a life hack. This is a razor that delivered don't you know it's adult product
Life a life hack. Maybe what would a life hack. We take this pill and never get cancer. That's a life hack
We have the we have the dollar shave club sugar yeah, alright
It's a live hack and a no-brainer you
No longer have to schlep to the store to buy cheap disposable
Razors that give you a cheap shave or spend a fortune on razors back with Gimmicky shaving Techni you didn't aid
So here's the deal
For limited time new members get their first month of the exclusive razor and a Tube
Some reason to cracks me up
You get a tube of Dr.. Carver's shave butter for only 5 bucks with free shipping that includes your tube of butter
Shave butter that is that helps you?
Not safe for human consumption. I so don't put that on the anyone thought just being clear
So you get a dang freakin tube of butter shea butter for cartridges and this beefy meaty
Very excellent shaver now. I use this anytime I clean up my neck and my cheeks and stuff because I've been to excellent
It's the only razor that doesn't give me razor burn. It's a really high quality stuff
I recommend a lot and it's super convenient razors are so fucking expensive you ever go to the store. They have like a 8 pack
Like 50 bucks my dad pointed out last time they put it behind glass yeah, I
Cut they do that. They freaking put it like high-end alcohol behind glass and lock it
so guys head on over to
dollarshaveclub.com Slash H3 and get your free exclusive razor for only five dollars with free shipping
cludes for cartridges a beefy meaty razor and a Tube of butter I
Recommend this product very much, and I appreciate them very much
So if you want to support the show and you're in the market for dreiser considered heading on over to dollarshaveclub.com
Hp and
finally
If you don't want any of those products, but you want to support the show
Or you want it those products and to support the show which is an option. I don't want to exclude
Then you can head on over to represent calm Slash H3 they pick up your official util Kleinert merge
Did we do this in the beginning? We did this trip in?
You guys don't need more of that shook mm-hmm. How we doing by the way. I'm not shirt
I'm gonna how much we sold ready so it's interesting on represent you can see how many people bought
27 Pouch doing planner is it where the heel decline is it?
Alright
Alright, I'm going to take a quick break to run to the bathroom guys
Hold on one sec didn't close to it. Oh yeah. I closed it in defiance of y'all
So we're going to just run to the bathroom really quick, and I'll be back in a short
Minute to begin our discussion about net neutrality if you go away
I just have a bad feeling I
Just have bad feeling about it. So please don't leave welcome back everybody to the H3 podcast live
So here we are to our main story
about net neutrality
Which has been a hotly debated subject recently and on Wednesday was net neutrality day of awareness
now
My objective for doing this piece. I want to explain to the best of my ability based on our research. What is it?
What's at stake?
Who are the people that benefit from it are there counter arguments against it so let's let's start from the top here
What is net neutrality?
Which is essentially the principle that internet service providers should?
enable access to all content and applications regardless of the source and without favoring or
blocking particular Products or websites and
To break that down that essentially just means a free and open internet one where
The internet companies have one job to give us the juice
They don't say what sites you can visit. They don't say what sites you can visit how fast?
They just give you the juice and we and we do what we want it's free and it's open
Here's here's what people have said the internet would look like without net neutrality
this is kind of like A
dystopian future of what it may look like
It's a lot like cable television where I'll have to pay for hBO
Hmm. Yep, right for and the internet that that's exactly right
These big companies Comcast Verizon, AT&t T-Mobile
They are trying to own the internet they want to own and control the internet, and this is what it's going to look like
eventually
You know it's like
You have to include Google yahoo, flickr this is old you know but YouTube Google yahoo, whatever
You have to pay $5 extra for this access to the search engines
Or you have to pay $5 extra so that they are quick enough that you can use
Yeah, then here's another one Hollywood, whatever entertainment YouTube hulu Netflix
Espn ETC $10 extra
like yeah sky Paypal Amazon
Right now this shit is illegal under FCC's rules
But without the principle of net neutrality which is what everyone's fighting for this is something that's very real and very possible and some things
That are already happening today. Which is something? I want to get I want to get at here
so from the beginning the FCC regulated the internet with their general rules known as net neutrality principle and
They started getting challenged from companies like Verizon back in the 90s when the internet was first created
the FCC, which is the
What does that stand for I?
see
Federal communications commission they control all the utilities and shit and they regulate it and they say what you can't can't do essentially
It's there to protect consumers
Americans who consume these products so the very beginning of the internet wouldn't be started becoming widely used they had this rule called
neutrality principles
Which in which the thing was that it was a free and open internet
that shouldn't be grabbed and controlled by big companies like Verizon and
incidentally they started getting challenged by companies like Verizon and
2014 a court ruled that FCC had no authority to an uP until 2014
FCC had some control over this in
2014 Verizon sued the FCC and a court ruled that they had no authority to enforce
Network neutrality rules because the internet was not considered a title 2 utility like telephones buses taxis Etc
which is like a
Service that exists for the public good yeah
And so there's a lot more restrictions or regulations on what big companies can do with that service?
so what is a title 2 so this whole debate about net neutrality is essentially trying to get the internet classified as a
Title 2 utility
right now or
Previously it was a title one utility which I think is like you said cable Mm-hmm. It's not a public utility really
It's just entertainment, but the internet is clearly much more than that
Yeah
At this point. It's like just life
Like it's like the blood of our economy of our society it's it's more of a public utility that anything that's ever existed
You compare it to telephone lines or sewage or anything? It's as much as that as as anything
That's ever existed and way more. It feels like pointless to even try to explain why like
Like when I hate when someone asks you to explain the meaning of an piece of art, right?
What you know no, you know you know the internet is like
It's everything at this point, and it's so stupid to even have to try to explain
I agree, it's it's the lifeblood are as of our society and the world as we know it
It's even beyond it so let me define for you guys what a title 2 is, and that's what this battle is about ok
So it shall be unlawful for any common carrier to make unjust or unreasonable discrimination and charges practices
classification regulations facilities or services for or in connection
with like communication services directly or indirectly by any means or device or to make or give any undue or
unreasonable preference or
Advantage to any particular person class of persons or locality or
To subject any particular person class of persons or locality to any due or unreasonable prejudice or disadvantage. That's
What being a title 2 is?
They're saying you can't manipulate it. You can't favor anyone any service. It's a public. Good it is what it is. It's free and open
Another part of being a title - that's part a part B
is changes or services whenever transferred - and this act include charges for or
Services in Connection with the use of common carrier lines of communications whether derived from wire or radio facilities enchain?
Broadcasting or incidental to radio communications
see any carrier who knowingly violates the provisions of this section Shall forfeit to the United States the sum of
$6,000 for each such offence and 300 for each and every day of the continuance of such offence
So the FCC's like you have to pay up if you fuck around with this shit
now
there's a debate of
People who say the internet shouldn't be regulated because they believe that the free market
Should be the controlling factor and that company shouldn't be regulated and they should be free to do what they want. That's a separate argument
I'm arguing but even before that the internet is a title to utility
If you're going to say that the internet shouldn't be regulated and Verizon and Comcast
Should be able to do whatever they want then let's hand the sewage and the taxis and the buses and the telephone lines
Because they don't even come close in my opinion that the internet doesn't in terms of public good that
Argument is is comes after the fact that it is a public utility?
Mmm-Hmm, I don't see any reasonable way to debate that it's not I really don't
So fucking internet, Pro
It's like yes, it offers entertainment such as cable, but there's so much more not the lifeblood of our society
So that's kind of what a title to us
And that's what this whole thing is about trying to get the internet under a title to utility now incidentally
in
2015 other than president Obama and his head of the sec net neutrality was actually granted to the internet
It was a huge victory for I remember when it happened on Reddit that they actually
Finally after all debate and everything they gave title to classification and dema protected as utility they received
3.7 million comments and requests to change the classification. I remember when that happened. It was a huge victory and everyone was excited
now
The FCC's new order established a standard that required internet providers to take no action that
Unreasonably interfere or disadvantage consumers or the companies who sites and apps they're trying to access?
this was deemed in 2015 when it became a title to at most internet providers may slow down services only for the purpose of
unreasonable or
For the purpose of reasonable network management. I was the only reason they could throttle internet services not a business purpose
So now this year trump's appointed Chairman Pi pay
Wants to ditch the title 2 and return to the FCC's light touch title 1 approach?
And so title 1 is like
What we we're talking about that's just a business. Yeah, the thing is no, so the translation there is that?
That current chair of the FCC wants to give the control of the internet back to the companies
and the thing is like people say well, you know if you go back before it was fine and
I think that counter-argument to that is that
before
When verizon sued the FCC and the Court said well
You can't actually regulate this because its title 1 which is a fair ruling considering. That is true
the FCC had more control over
over the internet
But there was this legal precedent that took control away from them
And so the need for it to stay a title 2 became greater
So now they want to go back to how it was
Except with this legal precedent the companies can run amok essentially gives them free rein to do whatever they want with the internet
The thing that blows my mind about I just understand like why what is it?
This Chairman what is his reason and to give them that control dan what were you saying previously?
Can you come in here does that Mic work?
Tom I could work we would have to just plug it in
So this this chairman dan what were you saying about this guy?
this whole whole deal is he he
He was like the dissenting voice in
the previous administration, so like when Obama was doing the whole thing and he was trying to
What he call it
Reclassified as title - yeah
this guy the current Chairman he was on the council and
He was against it vehemently because he I think it one. I wanted to write something right, so he was that one
He was yes exactly and so as soon as the new administration came in boom I gets promoted. He's now the commissioner and
Of course immediately he does what he said he always want to do which is keep it the way it used to be correct
So they can just deregulate it right. Thank you. Yep. Thanks, Dan
This is brought to you by your dan on visual update
So to try to answer your question eula the only thing I can think of is like the conditions kind of conservative
Economic vision of America is like free market unregulated you let the market figure itself
And it's kind of this this beautiful vision. They have of the free market yeah, and I think it's some cases that works
but in the case of
Companies like Verizon Comcast AT&t, I don't trust these fucking people. I'm gonna get into that a lot later
You know so they're they already have so much control like they've already made it to the top. What else is there to give them?
What what do we what are they in abling them to do? What else is in yeah? They're they're already at the top
That's a good point
And we've already given them our trust
And they fucked over the whole country which is something an adding to a story that I want to share later a reason
Why we shouldn't trust these companies?
So the thing that blows my mind about this is the FCC. Is there it's a regulatory board. It's there to protect consumers a
Rolling back the changes to net neutrality would probably benefit 20 people to a thousand people
I'm talking about the ceos of these telecom companies and the shareholders
Literally everybody else in the con tree
300 million people stand to get fucked
Everybody else from the word right yeah this stuff trickle down to the the rest of the world these kind of policies I
Just don't understand though. I mean, it's like the impact of this will be so
negative to so many
99.9999% of the people it just says the word that anything that we even have to have this conversation. It's insane
Well, there's this great quote that out that I read in context of this the price of freedom is an eternal vigilance
It's like you never get to give up this fights been going on
For years. It's like every month every year I see the same headline net neutrality is under attack
Yeah, and it's like fuck like not this shit again
You know us here in America in this American Democracy that we all take for granted
You forget that the price of freedom is eternal?
Vigilance
Mmm-hmm, we're all so fucking lazy. We're all so take the ship for granted that when you get lazy
And you don't remember that you have to fight for it every year forever
Then all these fucking these people
They they'll take it for you, and you know and you'll be happy about it
It's like Mike tyson famously said I'm going to fuck you till you love me faggot
That's what Comcast is essentially doing to us and we love it, and we love it
They fucked us in the ass and now we love it
So and wonder what would happen to people like us. Oh
basically our whole
living and Livelihood is
related to the internet all right well the really like
dystopian nightmare vision and something that's completely possible they can go so far as
Throttling or disabling service or access to a site to a channel
to a competitor
And the thing is you don't even have multiple
Carrier options if you're in certain parts of the country you only have access to 18 to you or you only have access to comm
Cat so if comcast says all of a sudden. I don't like H3H3 productions
I don't want our users to be able to visit them
and you don't even have an option you don't have an altar then you don't get to watch HD reproductions and
There's no regulation right? It's totally totally in their power
now I
Want to say to the people who are sick who do say the counter-argument that net neutrality should be eliminated because it's just another government
regulation that an unnecessary
Unnecessarily hinders business and free market I want to give you guys a glimpse into the future without net neutrality
By giving you example of violations that have already happened
here's a list starting in 2005 of telecom
companies violating net neutrality and
This is during a time when it wasn't acceptable in the FCC was able to sue them and take and challenge them imagine
How crazy it's going to get when they have full rein so let me let me start here
2005 Madison River, North Carolina ISp, Madison River Communications, blocked the voice over internet Protocol service Vonage
Bondage is like Skype for your telephone, okay? My parents lived in Mexico. They got a local
California number from Vonage so you could call them without incurring international fees yeah
Bondage file to complete with the FCC after receiving a slew of customer complaints the FCC stepped and distinction
Madison River and prevent further blockage, but it lacks the authority to stop this kind of abuse today
so
This is p
Was like this vantage of stealing business from us so without saying anything to anyone
We're just going to block access so all the sudden anyone with them can't fucking call. They can't use this service
Consists doesn't work doesn't work film I
Mean this is some like North Korea shit. Yeah in my opinion. This is not American
Comcast in 2005 the Nation's largest ISp Comcast began secretly blocking peer-to-peer
Technologies that its customers were using over its network use users of services like Bittorrent
gee Nutella work
I don't know that one is theirs anyway like bittorrent were unable to contact connect to these services
2007 investigations from the associated press and the e ff and others confirmed that conk
Comcast was indeed blocking or slowing file sharing
Applications without disclosing this fact to its users is such a nightmare. So here you are
Maybe ok maybe you're using peer-to-Peer technology for something that's not illegal
It's a pretty wonderful thing. It's amazing Peer-to-Peer technology Comcast without saying word
Blocks nobody or it just slows it down
Slows it down to unusable speeds. Which is almost more nefarious. Yeah
Working, but you don't know what's wrong. You're going to the settings trying to figure it out, and you're like. Oh, man
This is America Comcast won't do that. No
in
telus
Canada's second largest
Telecommunication company began blocking access to a server that hosted a website supporting a labor strike against the company
How about that?
Researchers at Harvard and the University of Toronto found that this action resulted in Talia's blocking an additional
766 unrelated sites
So here you have a company directly
suppressing a
Political movement that wasn't alive of their interests
created
AT&T from 2007 to 2009 AT&T Force apple to Block Skype and
other competing
videophone services on the iPhone the
Wireless provider wanted to prevent iphone users from using any application that would allow them to make calls on such
over-the-top voice services the Google voice app receives similar treatment from carriers like AT&t when it came on the scene in
2009 so imagine you're on you're at home. You're on your wireless, and you can't use facetime
Because att forced apple to block it because it competes with their own service
It's just going backwards in life like I
Just don't know why it's such this romantic free-market ideal to just lay and let me fuck you in that yeah
It's just not romantic to me. I'm sorry
Windstream in 2010 Windstream communications a deal DSL provided with more than 1 million customers at a time copped to
Hijacking user search queries made using the Google Toolbar Within Firefox
Users who believe they had set the browser to the search engine of their choice were
Redirected to win streams own search portal and results
Yes, it's crazy
so if you're using the Google search engine
This is p windstream hijacked it to redirect that traffic and inquiries to their own search engine I
Can't believe that the this company did this stuff when it was illegal, too?
These are the guys who got caught yeah?
Soon these rules won't even apply and they can do all this shit that they want
Metro PC, and
2001-2011
Metro PC at the time
One of the top 5 us carry Wireless carriers announced plans to block streaming video over its 4G. Network from all sources
except YouTube
Metro PC
Then threw its weight behind Verizon's court challenge against the FCC in 2010 open internet ruling hoping that
rejection of the Agency's Authority would allow the company to
continue its anti consumer practices so metro PC says if you're on our wireless carrier 4g that you pay for the
blocked all streaming video except YouTube
I
Mean YouTube how much so essentially they're shaking down Youtube they're blackmailing Youtube or youtube's compliant in this were they're like
Hey, I'll pay you 20 million dollars, and you block everyone else
There's a huge money-making scheme for companies are already making money hand over fist
packs fire
2011 the Electronic the Efs found that several small iSPs were redirecting search queries via the vendor packs fire the iSPs
identified an initial electronic frontier foundation report include a caviar cognate Frontier fuse
Direct PC RcN and wide open West packs fire would intercept a person's search request at Bing and yahoo
And redirected to another page by skipping over the search
Services results the participating iSp would collect referral fees for delivering users to select websites
18t and Sprint and Verizon from 2011 to 2013 Att Sprint resident blocks Google Wallet A
mobile payment system that competed with a similar service called Debenhams isis
I'm not showing you
This the competing service was called is is
Which all three companies had a stake in developing well you heard it here 18 t Sprint Verizon started isis
Somehow I'm not surprised
In Europe 2012 reports from the body of the European regulatory. Oh for electric. That's a mouthful
Communications found the violation of net neutrality affected at least one in five users in Europe the report found that blocked
Found that blocked or slow connections to services like video
You know ideal apps Peer-to-Peer technologies gaming applications emails were commonplace
Verizon in 2012 FCC caught Verizon Wireless blocking people from using tethering applications on their phones
Verizon had asked google to remove 11 free tethering applications from the Android marketplace these applications allowed users to circumvent
Verizon's $20 tethering fee and turn their smartphones into Wi-Fi Hotspots
Using their own Wi-Fi signal by the way
it seems like by blocking those applications Verizon violated net neutrality pledge it made to the FCC as a condition of the
2008 Airwaves auction
18 t in 2012 18 t announced that it would disable the facetime video calling app on its
Customers iphone unless they subscribe to a more
text-To-Voice plan
Att had one goal in mind
separating customers from more of their money by blocking alternatives
18t blocked disabled facetime on all their customers phones
Verizon during an oral argument in
2013 Verizon verse FCC a judge asked whether the phone giant would favor some preferred services content or sites?
Over others if the court overruled the Agency's existing open internet rules
Verizon's Lawyer had this to say I'm
Authorized to state for my client today, but for these rules. We would have already been exploring these types of arrangements
Walker's Admission may have gone on notice that she had not repeated it several times during the argument so here
They are basically saying if it wasn't for the rules we would already be exploring these options
and I mean they're already doing it regardless and
Again, what will the internet look like without these FCC regulations wells can look like this here
that's going to be your menu on your
telephone Bill and your cable Bill
your internet Bill Mm-Hmm, and
The United States already has the most expensive internet almost on the planet earth. Yeah. There's no competition if you put in Israel
I was shocked by the price there. What was it?
I'm sure we're paying like I
Mean if you translate it to dogs
I don't only $25 ain't I'm like five dollars a month for like some really excellent internet, then yeah
25 a month I paying $100 now over
I don't think you can get good internet for less than hundred dollars now and also the cell phone
Company $5.00 a month. We're paying for a cell phone or Japan $10
Unbelievable I go. I was shocked by that you know
So here this is my favorite part of this story
now once again
To counter the argument that we should not be regulating these companies. They should be free to
Invest and do whatever they want as the free market dictates
Here's a little story about these telecom companies and what I think is one of the greatest scandals in American history
These are the guys that we want to trust to deregulate, okay?
Let me read you this shit. It's absolutely shocking
It's it's it's horrifying
So the broadband companies stole two hundred billion dollars from the American government
Back in the 90 or back yeah back in the 90s during the Clinton, Era
They had this great vision that the United States would be the first
Broadband
high access high internet companies
They wanted to catapult the United States into the future and give it the infrastructure to be the technological
Touchstone
What happened because now the United States has won the slowest internet speeds of any?
Developed country, we're all last on the list almost last on the list
This shit is horrifying so buckle up
basically yeah in the 1990s Clinton-gore
era had an aggressive plan to create the National infrastructure
Initiatives to rewire all of America with fiber optic wiring replacing the hundred-year-old copper wires the bell company
Verizon Bell South Quest claimed that they would step up the plate and
Rewire home schools libraries government agencies businesses and hospitals if they
Receive financial incentives to run the barrel to say this because it's not showing no, okay
by 2006
Eighty six million households should have been wired with fiber
The wiring was going to be done in rich poor neighborhoods in Rural Urban Suburban areas equally
It was open to all
competition
By 2006 by 2006 Seventy-five percent of the state of New Jersey was supposed to be wired
Pennsylvania was supposed to have 50% of households wired, California five million, Texas claimed schools libraries hospitals virtually all of the state
the government in exchange for
Building the networks were given huge financial perks such as tax cuts
Excessive prop not taxed on excessive profits shit like that
so
They estimate that on average the amount of money the government gave these telecom community companies to build the fire offices
Somewhere in the range of four to seven thousand dollars per household. We're talking about hundreds of
Millions to Five Hundred billion dollars were given to Verizon Comcast AT&T to build fiber optics throughout the country, so
What happened dude?
Let me tell you
Basically what happened? Is that they all promised the world and none of them did it?
none of them did the work
So the country made people pay that well it comes from taxes
They make their money so on average if you're thinking about how the government spends its taxes it
Was came out to four to seven thousand dollars per household
that's a lot half a
Trillion and
Nothing ever happened today. They're starting to roll out some fiber optics, but the thing is the government paid for this shit
It's supposed to be a public service yet
if you want fibers
You still have to pay out that ass for it so for the most part even in 2017 we still disclose internet
And it doesn't exist. No state has ever done an off and audit on the monies collected by the broadband companies
No state every went back and reduced the rates or held the companies accountable
No company ever outed the other companies Verizon, New Jersey never said the eighteen t
Didn't do it for example because they were all in on
These are the companies we want to deregulate you you should look into that stories. It's it's horrifying
So I
seriously one of the biggest scandals in American history and
I love that vision of America as like the technical center of the world Mm-hmm
Technologic we were going to be number one
Before anyone else was installing fiber optics. We gave them half a trillion bucks, and they all said thanks smell you later dumb-dumb
so now to get kind of back into the real world situation and
As we're saying the internet prices is the highest they've ever been pretty much the highest of any country on Earth
so the thought of
Increasing those prices in demand for net neutrality is probably less likely than what you're going to see from T-Mobile right now
Can you show this picture Dan?
So T-Mobile is already doing this shit called binge on why is it makings I push control plus
It makes it smaller the fuck is that about okay?
So you guys may have heard of this binge on they repainted as this wonderful great thing for you
Video is now streaming free without using your data cap only on T-Mobile, so if you're watching videos on YouTube Amazon hBO now?
Netflix Sling Hulu ESPN Fandango. It doesn't affect your data cap
well, what is the
What are they selling it is I don't understand. It's just a perk if you use T-Mobile MmM-hmm. These don't affect your data cap
But the money is coming from somewhere it's a shakedown of these big companies hmM. You know
It's the that cost is being passed on to these companies instead of you and what it also does is it strangles out?
It's funny they have this vision of like deregulate the market
But these companies are preventing competition by if you're not Youtube
And you're making a new YouTube create to better
Yeah
You don't have a fucking chance because to watch great new Tube your data plan which is already bullshit to begin with yeah
you're getting you you end up paying more to watch something else so all is it doing is in granting the powers that be and
Strangle holding any new competition
But it's confusing because I thought that t-Mobile had plans like we we have it that that's one plan not everyone has unlimited
Yeah, not everyone has we're all non limited, but a lot of people are on data
you know and
More companies Data thing is oh yeah
The Data thing is total is total bullshit does it cost them more to bring you data is ridiculous and cut more and more companies
are moving towards data caps and
Internet providers who for the past what 20 years have given you unlimited internet are now moving towards data caps
And that's how this net neutrality thing is going to take form through Data caps words like
YouTube Gets an exception so just watch YouTube
Don't think or watch or look at steam gets an exception. So don't try this other gaming
Service that's coming up and better
Then it gives YouTube and steam the power to monopolize and fuck you over
Yeah
It's just these old crony businesses and bed together and trenching the powers-that-be and making it impossible for new competitors to come up
It's pretty horrifying and they the worst part is they disguise it as this wonderful thing binge on brother big brother
They make it a sweet pill to swallow. It's like point. You know they say they help to say poison is sweet
Split it met a spoonful of sugar makes the medicine go down right  pretty horrifying reality
That this is what I'm saying this shit is is it's tricky
This net neutrality shit is tricky. It's
manipulative it's dirty we're talking about Comcast the
Every year voted the most hated
Company on Earth you search Comcast on Google images and a nazi, Swastika comes up
I'm not kidding by the way let me do that. They've been memed on so hard
Okay, my point is do you trust these companies?
Where's that Swastika at?
Google is in bed! the people do this every day on you okay? Yeah, google Google's in bed with Comcast. They removed that shit
My point is do you trust these companies?
Do you? me I would never. Have they given you any reason to trust them to deregulate them?
Are they the ones who stole half a trillion dollars?
From the government are they the ones who are already violating net neutrality who are already having this binge on brother!
AT&T came out on the day of action to support net neutrality
That can you believe that AT&T? We support net neutrality of course the irony not lost on us
since
AT&T which in 2012 blocked customer access to Apple's facetime let's say subscribe to a more excessive plan
AT&T who spends Millions of dollars lobbying to reverse the FCC's?
reclassification of broadband providers as common carriers under title two
The very same protests that they are participating in to prevent
Fact AT&T already sued the FCC in 2015 over this and lost but of course att supports net neutrality
to confuse the issue
these fuckers are tricky that's such a joke that they would say that they're
disgusting they just they pray to the almighty dollar and
It's what I'm saying. It's tricky. It's confusing their manipulative with this binge on think good AT&T supports net neutrality for
Me it's it's I don't know
It's kind of like it became like a trendy thing for the big companies to say that they support it. Yeah
and to the Layman who just like it's a buzzword net neutrality, right?
To the person is just sitting at home
Watching the local news watching the daily news and they hear this buzz work they don't really understand it
They're like oh AT&T sports it binge on you know don't regulate the internet. What do I what do I know who cares?
the internet was created and funded by the governments and scientists  very beginning as a
Public utility was never meant to be owned by companies like Comcast AT&T T-Mobile and Verizon
people will never have the
the best interest of people never
So to that. I just say the price of freedom is eternal, Vigilance and
Just by talking about it
I think we raise awareness just by educating people and sharing in this experience of saying like this is shit. I
Acknowledge that this is just a huge money grab that will benefit a thousand people at the expense of 300 million
Or more and it and like it
This is just this whole beginning of this this whole divide of like the super wealthy and normal people
This is the beginning if you hand over net if you get rid of net neutrality the internet is our is our only source of
organizing
communicating
Participating in democracy this is the lifeblood of our modern society we forfeit that to these companies also, you're going to
leave everything in the hands of this big companies to
Decide what is what like how are they even going to decide? What goes in which plan you know what I mean like
does ready go and a
Facebook kind of right A
Branded they are going to charge this much far does it go with Wikipedia?
And they're going to charge this much for it because they're gonna bundle it with the Christian like network just to make you pay more
It's like who is going to be making this decisions?
People will probably have no idea what they're talking about of course
It's like a real dystopian future. I mean this is the beginning of some really horrible slippery slope
so I say
Share the awareness let these politicians out there know who are who are you know?
speaking and voting in support of getting rid of net neutrality that
If they do they forfeit their jobs let them know that your you don't agree with that
If you go to a website battle for the Netcom which I'll put in the description and here in the chat right now
Then you can easily fill out a form on
This page with your name email address zip code telephone number and a letter to the FCC in your government body to congress
saying that you don't support it and
Have your voice be heard?
So that's pretty much it. That's pretty much all I have to say about that now
Just by understanding the issue and knowing what it means and knowing what your opinion about it
Is it already helps you know because?
The worst is when people vote on something they have no idea. What it actually means
Like a lot of people were saying with brexit
people voted and only afterwards realized what they voted for I think in this day and age when there's
Something at stake or something to the vote that
Disadvantages the majority of people who would vote on it. It's this war of information
Of confusion, that's the only way stuff like this wins because if people understood what it was it would never never pass. So they spend
millions of dollars on campaigns and
Influencing information why they own like why rupert murdoch of all people owns like almost every
telecom company, I don't know I'm telling you this is important guys, so
if you're if you're in the comments
I'm curious. I haven't heard a really persuasive counter-argument
And I wonder if there is one if you happen to have one or you think that you have an interesting counter-argument
I'd love to hear it in the comments
But anyway guys not the most funny or or fucking light-hearted one, but I thought it would suit it was
suiting considering the
situation we're in
We made a video about it previously on H3 H3 and I?
Really think it's important more more important important than then most people understand
People are saying "Call Joey" in the chat,
do you want to call him? And now to finish off this podcast, let's call up Joey.
Dude don't give a fuck about net neutrality let me just call Joey
This is the last episode I'm being serious on
Nobody cares. They just want here Joey salads. No, they will care.
Let's get Joey on the phone.
(Hopefully he's taking a dump like last time)
Joey you're live. Oh damn.
Yeah, how you doing? Caught me off guard. I was jerking it. Just assume every time I call you, it's on the-
It's live. Oh.
Well yeah, I was jerking it. Oh my God. I was saying
I hope you're taking a shit. Do you usually answer the phone when you're jerking off, when your friends call you?
Only when I call you. and it accidentally cause the the answer bothers. What are you watching?
I'm just trying to park my car
What you're trying to fuck your phone?
I'm trying to park my car. Oh you're not wrong. That's what scientists started, so I'm just curious ago, Canada
I'm just curious if there's any soflo updates
um
You shared another video, okay? Tell me how big you put me in like a group with his goon
And you going to sharing me. Oh, you got the girl
We asked for not the goon shares though
We said four leglock shares
But it was at a good time, but there was like his girl like you did pasta sharing
So it wasn't on the so flow page
No, it's is sharing people source about you like don't want to work for them, and then they shared me on proform, okay?
Good excellent. So your so just to keep the count you're at two legit Shares and one nighttime share
Yeah, so it might be any solos you one-and-a-half more shares
Yeah, okay. We're going to keep we're going to follow this closely make sure or my name isn't oak Francis the third
All right, Jelly. Well. I hope you're doing well
Yeah, thank you keep it up on things. I wish you the very best. What do you what are your opinions on net neutrality?
I'm I don't even know anything about it. Okay. That's right a quick left down there. I'll tell you my opinion
Um we just talked about it for like an hour and a half
No, yeah, I'm not sure if people are ready to rehash that but you know what would one mistake like this
I was I would want it to be the most the most free version of the internet where less government control
Whatever, whatever option that would be like router situation. So that's the complicated matter is where it's like
free and government control almost contradict each other in this case because
Without the government control the big companies are making it less free
Hmm
All right the companies have control in the government really really
Yeah, so this is Subtle trust and girl were lucky
Wow, that's it. So even if the company organic things work, so so this is what's happening?
Tell me what you think the government is saying
They're passing a law net neutrality which means nobody can regulate it. They says the company
They make it illegal for the companies to control the internet. That's the whole purpose of the regulation wow
That's what I mean like a government government Bill
essentially, they're they're saying the internet is free is open and nobody can control it then on the other hand the
Telecommunication companies are saying I don't want you to regulate it because I want to control it
So let me give me I got the research on this before. I got that's very complicated I do research
I love to I'd love to talk with you about it because you seem like someone who would who would be against net neutrality?
And I think this would be a really fruitful conversation
Yeah, definitely ah I'm going to research a little bit
I mean, I don't know how long you're going to be live for if you want to talk about it. That's not okay
I'm gonna. Call you up next week. I love this this weekly Joey so update with the meld man
Weekly salad yeah, the weaker dog
How good all right so do some homework? I'm let's talk about it next week
All right cool all right. That sounds great. I wish you the very best my friend and I wish you a very very ranchi evening
Thank you, alright. Peace did well, but but
Love that guy love the salad man
This is where dreams are born man
You start beaming on a guy you call him a solid head and shit and now you're best friends
That's the end of the po po law. What was it poe's law. That's like. It's a
Continuation of where we started this episode full circle, all right? I guess that's about it
That boring nobody cares good. We just want to laugh
Sometimes I got to get serious though it is important. I think it's important to me
But that's the way the cookie crumbles my friends so with that I
Wish you all the very best. We'll do a little after-show so don't go away but for the purpose of the podcast
I say thank you all so much for watching thanks for watching and next week
We'll be back with Jack films and Eric from common etiquette and the week after that
You will not want to miss because we have rudy pantalla Jr.. Aka
humongous joining us
We're flying him out from Seattle and we're putting them up, and I'm super excited. I mean talk about vip guests, okay?
That's incredible. We're going to meet them demand to myth the legend himself
So thank you guys all for watching and we shall see you next week. Goodbye peace